anna is with us in Iowa Anna welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up so I am
going to be getting married in May and I
will be in there my fiance has a lot of
debt so I'll be marrying into that and I
am totally on board with the baby steps
and your whole thought process and
philosophy when it comes to getting out
of day and so on and so forth but my
fiance is having a little bit of a
harder time getting on board because he
wants to experience life a little bit
but I'm like he won't have the funds to
do that so I'm trying to get him to get
on board but I don't know how to do that
okay how old are you guys I am 23 and he
was 28 he's going to be a doctor oh good
for him
medical doctor MD he is going to be a
deal a deal okay and when will he get
his only graduate he will be graduating
a week before we get married oh great
and how much debt does he have three
hundred and forty thousand okay
IDL you said I don't know what that is
I'm sorry I'd be it's a deal
it's osteopathic medicine oh okay okay
all right and how long have you guys
been dating we've been together for
almost three years okay and how much
pre-marriage counseling have you done we
are actually in the midst of it right
now
good okay bring this up with your
marriage counselor okay the reason I
tell you that is the number one reason
the couples fight in America today and
the number one cause of divorce in
America today is money fights and money
problems you have both you're marrying a
broke doctor yeah you are marrying into
a freaking mess and in people who study
medicine generally like him are are
intellectually brilliant people
and sometimes what goes with that is
they think that that makes them
intellectually brilliant about every
subject and a lot of doctors that I meet
are arrogant and broke for that reason
mm-hmm I meet more music people who have
money than doctors broken doctors are a
stereotype in the business I'm in
because of what you're facing right
there we've got a young very smart man
very deeply in debt and he has confused
his intellect with his ability to grasp
what the debt is and he and you're
marrying into this so it's not it's not
a death sentence it's the patient is not
terminally ill they can be brought back
around but I think your marriage
counselors probably the best place to do
that but if you marry this guy and he is
intent on being in in not dealing with
this huge freaking mess he is made you
are gonna have a long life darling it's
gonna be it's gonna be problems you're
gonna have problems cuz you're calling
me already asking for help so we know
there's gonna be problems right so he's
not a bad guy he's a very smart guy he's
a very disciplined person because you
don't finish med school without being
smart and disciplined so he's got a lot
of wonderful attributes you've picked a
fine young man to marry except for this
one problem that's gonna have to be
dealt with and I would make a big deal
out of this and the pre marriage
counseling if I were you this is the
same advice I would give my daughter
where I counseling her on this issue
okay because it's a problem I mean if
the number one cause of divorce in North
America were green cars you would never
buy a green car right so whatever the
main cause of problems are you stay away
from it is my point
and you guys are walking straight into
it so you've got to be on the same page
on how you're gonna fight it and if
you're on the same page that you can
take his wonderful new income he's going
to make and clean up this horrible
message made pretty quick
he's gonna have a big shovel to go with
the big Holies in so he's gonna be okay
as long as he graduates and passes his
boards and everything you're gonna be
fine but you're not gonna be fine with
his Yolo mentality you only live once
thank God it's Friday
oh god it's Monday this is that this is
the language of losers
okay and you so I'm trying to scare you
without being melodramatic I'm not
telling you to call off the wedding but
I am saying warning warning warning
warning bridge out slow down make sure
the bridge is in place take a detour
whatever you got to do here but
hopefully he'll come around pretty
quickly I'll help you with that
and you can play this back for him
because everything I said about him is
true and I'm happy to say it to his face
because I really think he's a smart guy
I really do
he's just not wise there's a difference
in intellect and wisdom and so I better
hold on I'll have Kelly pick up I'm
gonna give you a wedding present it's
called Financial Peace University it's a
nine week class you can go ahead and
take that before the wedding it'll be a
complement to your pre marriage
counseling and if he goes through that
class
I'll get him don't worry about it I'll
turn him around if you can get him to go
to the class I'll get him so and I'm
gonna give it to you free by the way
didn't I'm losing money on this
transaction just to help you but then
someday when you guys are rich doctors
and you're out of debt you can help some
young doc who's getting ready to make
the same mistake